es gibt pflegeroboter und militär
roboter roboter rasenmäher und sex
roboter alle diese maschine näher fühlen
einen zweck sie sollen uns arbeit
abnehmen uns unterhalten trösten
der heute bei uns zu gast ist ist anders
er lernt von sich aus und trifft eigene
entscheidungen über wir uns denken und
darüber was hier von robotern erwarten
können uns wovor wir uns vielleicht zu
fürchten brauchen diskutiere ich heute
hier am gottlieb duttweiler institute in
rüschlikon und zwar diskutiere ich mit
manfred hild er ist mathematiker und
psychologie und leitet das
forschungslabor europa vatikan der beuth
hochschule für technik in berlin
und er ist wenn man das so sagen darf
dass chefs abonnieren und ich diskutiere
mit thomas metzinger ist professor für
philosophie an der universität mainz und
direktor der dortigen forschungsstelle
neurotiker herzlich willkommen
na ja und herzlich willkommen auch dir
million oder vielleicht ihnen mio
ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht so recht
davon nutzen es ist alles erlaubt und
interessant war auch schon in der
anmoderation die geschlechterfrage
tatsächlich interessiert ist mal sehr
viele leute also ist eigentlich ein
androgynes wesen
man kann auch einen projizieren was man
will nun ist ja kein schaum roboter her
kann ich hier nicht irgendwelche
tänzchen aufführen er ist auch kein
service roboter der zu einem bestimmten
zweck geschaffen wurde sondern ist ein
forschungsroboter sie wollen
herausfinden die intelligenz
funktioniert ja also ist für uns ein
werkzeug philosophen haben sich seit
jeher mit dem phänomen intelligenz
beschäftigt dann gibt es auch mediziner
die gerne gucken wo das gehirn
aufleuchtet es gibt die psychologen die
zum beispiel experimente machen und
gucken wie sich das system mensch
verhält und wir könnten sagen wir sind
synthetische psychologen die sagen wenn
wir denn denken wir wüssten wie
bestimmte dinge funktionieren dann
müssen wir es eigentlich in den roboter
bringen können und mit dem interagieren
und
mit mir machen wir genau das was ist
denn eigentlich künstliche intelligenz
naja das ist zb die fähigkeit auf nicht
biologischen trägersystemen dass ein
system sich ziele setzen kann und diese
auch festhalten kann und verfolgen kann
durch rationales handeln
dass es also versucht auch in die
zukunft zu planen und unsicherheit zu
minimieren seine eigenen ziele zu
erreichen plant man in die zukunft
heute abend sicherlich nicht aber
derzeit ungefähr zwei jahren schreibt
nun auf seiner speicherkarte so eine art
episodische gedächtnis mit die dinge die
er wenn man so will erlebt aber kann man
ganz sachlich sachen die wieder fahren
oder was er tut wo er seine
aufmerksamkeit entwendet und es gibt
studierenden die jetzt mechanismen
versuchen zu implementieren die da
dieses diese gedächtnisinhalte nehmen
und in die vergangenheit gucken um dann
künftig zu sehen habe ich so was schon
mal erlebt und kann ich eine angenehme
situation wieder herbeiführen und das
genau in die zukunft denken
wir sehen auf dem monitor was mir und
sieht oder vielleicht müsste man eher
sagen was leon filmt im moment findet
der gerade diesen kurs hier glaube ich
interessant macht sich mir und irgend
einen reim darauf ja also man hat keinen
zentralen rechner oder kein zentralen
computer wie wir das gewohnt sind sonst
seien viele systeme die parallel
arbeiten über den ganzen körper verteilt
kleine rechner knoten natürlich auch im
kopf des roboters und wir sehen hier es
gibt denn das den blick durch das auge
des roboters und da sind verschiedene
sachen zu sehen linien die hin und her
wandern und zahlen die sich bewegen also
man sieht ein bisschen was für die
lautstärke verschiedene mitglieder des
teams probieren unterschiedliche dinge
aus implementieren ist auf den roboter
und jeder hat so seine kleine anzeige
die er betrachtet ein
forschungsgegenstand ist zum beispiel
die aufmerksamkeit da komme vielleicht
spielt er noch dazu aber wenn man jetzt
im laufe des abends immer wieder guckt
was den mühen macht
dann sind es erstmal basale systeme der
wahrnehmung also ton und bewegung und
objekt also auf alle systeme der
wahrnehmung mich interessiert die frage
denkt nun ist das schon denken neuen
wahrnehmung ist die innere darstellung
von gegenständen denken fängt damit an
dass wir begriffe bilden also dass wir
ganze klassen von gegenständen in
unserem geist erfassen
ich weiß nicht gegeben dass wir das
heißen na ja also ich kann diesen kubus
wahrnehmen aber um ihn denkend als einen
kubus zu begreifen muss sich sozusagen
die menge aller kubi in meinem in meinem
geist erfassen können
also ich muss das als ein beispiel für
einen etwas allgemeinere klasse von
gegenständen erfassen können ich glaube
dass er das erst schrittweise erlernen
wird durch körperliche interaktion mit
vielen von solchen gegenständen genau
also es gibt was zum beispiel jetzt eine
masterarbeit ist die gerade entsteht ist
dieses wir haben ja im schlaf so eine
art müll aufräumen prozess ja wir gehen
dinge noch mal im geiste durch manche
jetzt vergessen wir an andere sachen
erinnern wir uns wieder so was ähnliches
wird auch in kürze auf million
stattfinden also diese seit jahren
geschriebenen episodischen dinge werden
durchforstet werden
und dann gibt es zwei kategorien die
besonders interessant sind nämlich
sachen die sich häufig wiederholen
der mann muss oft so rum sitzen also das
wird auf jeden fall eine körperlose
seien die extrem häufig vorkommt dafür
wird dann ein symbol ein sozusagen eine
kategorie in einem sogenannten
generellen welt gedächtnis angelegt was
ermöglicht dass man im episodische
gedächtnis diese ganzen vorkommnisse des
sitzens wegschmeißen einfach sagt ich
denn dann bleibt übrig ich habe viel
gesetzlich sie zwar viel rum
das ist ein erster schritt in die
richtung und dann im nächsten schritt
geht es auch auf bewegungen oder auf
objekte als auf dinge liebe es über das
visuelle system reinkommen
das ist genau das ja ja also solche
forschungsinstrumente sind eben sehr
nützlich und wichtig
das ist sehr interessante forschungen
nicht nur für ingenieure oder
informatiker sondern zum beispiel auch
für geisteswissenschaftler oder
philosophen weil wir sehen ja jetzt
schon dass es da so etwas wie
körperliche intelligenz gibt
intelligente kontrolle von bewegungen in
beziehung zur sinneswahrnehmung aber
irgendwie gibt es dann auch begriffliche
intelligenz das episodische gedächtnis
bildung von klassen und was natürlich
sehr spannend ist zu verstehen auch bei
uns selbst das ganze ist auch ein
vorgang der selbsterkenntnis ist wie es
dann unser begriffliches denken unsere
logische intelligenz verankert in
unserem körper verankert und wie ist sie
vielleicht in der evolution auch daraus
entstanden
jetzt muss ich mal glaube ich noch ein
beispiel noch mal fragen also nehmen wir
jetzt mal an ich habe verstanden was ein
apfel ist und ich kann jetzt auch
erkennen dass eine schrumpelige es
braunes gipfel mal war zumindest habe
erkannt dass das für diesem cluster ab
zugehört was hat das jetzt genau noch
mal mit körperlicher intelligenz zu tun
ja also das philosophisch schwierige
waren natürlich ganz am anfang ihrer
frage
wir nehmen mal an ich habe verstanden
was ein apfel ist das zu wissen ja also
es gibt leute die würden sagen das
bedeutet in allen möglichen welten
erkennen zu können was ein apfel ist das
können wir nicht und das kann der
roboter auch nicht also es ist eher so
dass wir immer abstraktere formen von
selbstkontrolle von wechselwirkungen mit
der umwelt erlernen
dadurch dass wir erst einen apfel
kennenlernen dann fünf dann 1000 und
dann bildet sich zum beispiel so was wie
ein prototyp eines apfels in unserem
geist oder in dem geist des roboters das
ist vielleicht genau genommen noch kein
begriff aber wir sehen dass das erlernen
von solchen abstrakten dingen nur durch
die leibliche wechselwirkung mit einer
wirklichen welt geschehen kann
vielleicht auch noch kurz in die kerbe
mit reingeschlagen ich würde lieber das
beispiel glas statt apfel nehmen also
hier trinkglas
es gibt wie ich behaupten würde kühne
wissenschaftler die sagen wenn man nur
eine sehr große maschine hat einen
computer und das internet an schließt
dann kann der intelligent werden weil
der kanal prinzipiell alles nachgucken
da könnte gucken glas das ist ein
material und das ist so geformt da kann
man irgendwas rein schütteln und so
weiter und so fort wenn man diesen
ansatz verfolgt kommt man natürlich vom
ast zum es tieren das ist halt kein ende
wenn man aber ein körper hat wenn man
den roboter baut und es steht da ein
glas und er ist sehr tollpatschig und
manchmal stößt auch im labor einfach was
um dann haben wir plötzlich durch einen
singulären event durch ein ereignis was
zufällig entstanden ist ein großes
semantisches feld wir haben ein geräusch
weiß vielleicht wie sich das anfangs
also versucht hast zugreifen es kann
auch kitschig sein
dann war da vielleicht wasser drin dann
kommt ein kurzschluss im wird
geschrumpfte und wer sagt es nicht gut
er wird ausgeschaltet also dieses ganze
na ja das muss man dann schon tun
dieses ganze drumherum gehört alles zum
konzept glas ist es eben eine
erlebniswelt und beobachtet vielleicht
dass ich daraus trinken auch wenn er
noch nicht begreift was es ist weil das
entzieht sich ihm weil er das nie selber
tun wird also hier sieht man auch schon
intelligenz und begriffs velten sind an
den körper gebunden und manche dinge
oder wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel leute
die blind geboren werden
da bilden sich andere erlebniswelten und
das ist kürzer zu dieser kategorie hinzu
und ist etwas was ich nicht aus dem
internet ziehen kann und was ich auch
nicht mehr kopieren kann eine erfahrung
macht mache ich und ich kann es vom
anderen nachplappern aber das ersetzt
nicht mein eigenes erleben werden wir
uns vorstellen es gibt sehr intelligente
roboter jetzt von außen betrachtet gibt
roboter die schlagen uns im schacht ich
schreibe und selbst den
schachweltmeister im schach oder es gibt
roboter die sind absolut perfekt in
quizshows das ist bei mir nicht so aber
deswegen nicht weil sie ihn eben nicht
all diese sachen einprogrammiert haben
es eben auch nicht alle gläser dieser
welt sondern es war dass sich selber
beibringen aber wie lernt man nur lernen
hat ihm sehr viele facetten
zunächst mal muss man sich dinge merken
das tut er schon
dann muss man die vielleicht auch wieder
abrufen und das kann man unbewusst
machen die müssen bewertet werden gut
oder schlecht das ist zum teil
vorgegeben bei uns auf jeden fall wenn
ein kind auf eine herdplatte fast dann
müssen nicht darüber diskutieren ob das
das wird es sofort merken dass es nicht
gut ist also wenn der eigene körper
schaden nimmt
solche systeme sind auch im roboter und
und viele mehr
da kommen wir vielleicht im laufe des
gesprächs noch so die müssen alle da
sein und wir versuchen jedes dieser
teilsysteme zu reduzieren und möglichst
wenig vorzugeben aber jetzt nochmal wie
lernt er war ja in der komischen oper
werde er einen auftritt in der oper
meist fair lady gut also ich gebe eine
ganze menge dinge lernen ja also der
roboter hatten nicht irgendwie getanzt
oder eliza doolittle gespielt sondern
der roboter aber ganz ja das habe ich
nicht zufrieden dass sie ihnen dass ihr
ein reh das ist immer interessant sie
haben gerade eine soziale halluzination
hinaus halten wir sagen
darüber werden wir auch noch stächele
genc ist im auge des betrachters in
diesem fall in ihrem auge also ein
einfaches beispiel die erste stufe ist
dass der roboter dinge aufsaugt erstmal
unbewertet mitprotokolliert das machen
wir die ganze zeit ohne dass es das auch
bewusst ist diesen stand hatte und dann
kommen da mechanismen die dass ich sage
mal das gedächtnisprotokoll ich sage
bewusst nicht das erlebte weil erleben
hat schon eine qualität eine empfindung
die dieses protokoll durchforsten und
sagen das kommt selten vor was waren
einzigartiges erlebnis was kam häufig
vor und daraus vielleicht mit kleine
kopien machen in angermund heißt
gedächtnisses dann können wir entweder
dieses gedächtnis angucken oder also
sozusagen in die wir mit bestimmten
werkzeugen da rein gucken oder aber
sprachfähigkeit einen roboter geben wir
werden auch hören er kann schon ein paar
dinge sagen aber das sind keine
gelernten worte sondern sind vorgegebene
dinge die uns sagen was gerade im
roboter passiert und dann könnte das
wäre der nächste stufe des lernens dinge
die er noch nicht kennt die dann auch
nicht in diesem generellen gedächtnis
findet
könnte er versuchen uns mitzuteilen wenn
es eine bewegung ist könnte die bewegung
noch mal machen
oder er muss sich dann irgendwie
mitteilen können und dann können wir
sagen dass ist stuhl oder das ist links
von oder über unter also konzepte
mitteilen die er dann als annotation als
bezeichnung an diesen abstrakten
gedächtnis sind halt macht das ist
sozusagen der forschungs plan und da es
in erste systeme da manches läuft gerade
im rahmen von arbeiten doktorarbeiten
oder masterarbeiten manche systeme sind
schon da was wir jetzt heute hier sehen
ist vor allen dingen das aufmerksamkeits
system das ist ein ganz wichtiges denn
der roboter muss wenn er ein gedächtnis
1 1 eine erlebnis protokoll mit schreibt
natürlich für eine gewisse zeit
fokussiert sein es gibt nichts
schlimmeres als kinder die ständig da
und dort gucken ja also das tut er schon
sie fokussieren auf etwas so eine frage
die wir kommt es wie wäre es denn wenn
es 100.000 dieser roboter gebe die in
ganz vielen ländern und verschiedenen um
welten auf dieser erde verteilt werden
und die über das internet verbunden
werden und einmal nachts um mitternacht
ihre lernerfahrung des tages zusammen
updaten würden und wieder runter laden
auf alle 100000 roboter wenn die
zusammen lernen würden aber sozusagen
naja einen geist im internet hätten
was würde dann passieren also ist lück
steals ein ein forscher der sich auch
mit der evolution von sprache
beschäftigt unter anderem hatte genau
dieses experiment gemacht damals hatte
er nur ein kopf genommen und hatte so
eine weiße tafel wo bestimmte objekte
sein konnten die auch verschoben werden
und die köpfe konnte das angucken und
die haben dann interne bezeichnungen
gebildet für diese sache die sie hatten
und haben dann sich darüber ausgetauscht
über sozusagen ein roboter kommt
sozusagen mal luna oder warner drei
objekte und es hätte jetzt blau bedeuten
können oder rund oder rechts von mir ist
erst mal unklar wenn dann der zweite
roger sagt mal luna und auf ein anderes
zeigt und es war das ist auch blau dann
haben sie sich darüber geeinigt jawohl
es wir könnten unter umständen dasselbe
main
und luxe deals hat auch den mühe und
roboter wir haben also mehrere von
möhren in solchen experimenten genommen
im hinblick auf körper gesten also arm
das funktioniert sehr gut
so kann man in richtung einer
gemeinsamen sprache kommen tatsächlich
also nur der kann ja so ein bisschen
gehen aber nicht so richtig die meisten
roboter stehen ja auf rollen weil gehen
unglaublich schwierig ist ja ich möchte
gerne mal sehen was kann denn der mann
jetzt genau mit seinen körper machen
also beim stehen beim gehen das machen
jetzt gleich mal sieht man dass linkes
und rechtes bein unterschiedlich
bewegungsabläufe machen und freut sich
schon genau wir werden jetzt praktischen
30 nationen wir sehen hier auch eine
mensch maschine interaktion diese vielen
roboter würden die gleiche interaktion
machen aber mit anderen partnern auf der
welt wo die würde immer anders ausfallen
und das ist glaube ich mehrere
doktorarbeiten in sich wie diese daten
die da entstehen würden überhaupt
zusammenpassen wie man die
zusammenbringt vielleicht machen wir
erstmal was praktisches also was wir
jetzt hier sehen ist zum teil gescriptet
sie kennen das sie kommen ist in
restaurants sie wissen sie setzen sich
selber oder werden dahin gesetzt also
man weiß wie das so abläuft aber dann
innerhalb des skriptes gibt es viele
freiheiten
hier ist das skript wir stehen wir waren
lassen den roboter aufstehen vielleicht
musst du das mal machen
der roboter bevor du loslegst sagt dann
auch stehen sitzen aktiv der teilt uns
also mit über seinen internen zustand in
interne körperwahrnehmung ist auch mal
sehr wichtig meister jetzt schauen was
kommt lebt zwar tatsächlich nicht okay
das war wahrscheinlich kriegt er das
jetzt nicht wenn sie ihn anfassen genau
also sozusagen über die sensorische über
gelenk winkel und hoch locker fest sie
mehr hoch locker fest
ein bisschen schräg so
also das war jetzt eine für mich
ästhetisch nicht ganz so elegante
aufgewertet
es hat sozusagen trotzdem geklappt heute
nachmittag sah das sehr viel eleganter
aus das ist also jedes mal ein bisschen
anders der roboter versucht jetzt auch
ein bisschen zu balancieren
ja ich glaube du wirst jetzt vorne auf
die füße machen denn jetzt
er lehnt sich jetzt sozusagen gegen die
kraft und jetzt so langsam kommt ja in
die balance also wenn man ein joystick
hätte wohl jeder motor drauf ist würde
man sehen wie schwierig es tatsächlich
ist wenn man so ein system baut merkt
man dass gerade die sachen die für uns
selbstverständlich und trivial sind wie
sitzen stehen man das mich auf dem auf
dem angenehmen sessel aufrecht sitzen
ist eine komplexe körperliche leistung
ich meine warum brauchen kleinkinder so
lange bevor sie krabbeln stehen und dann
stabil stehen können ein ganzes jahr
weil die ganzen mussten koordiniert
werden hier haben wir ungefähr 50
motoren und ungefähr 200 sensoren und
die müssen im ersten zusammenspiel das
stehen erbringen
und hier kommt noch hinzu dass wir haben
uns gesehen diese aktion war komplex
dass diese gelenke hier das knie und die
hüfte
sie müssen einmal mit der kraft gegen
und einmal sich dagegen stellen wir am
anfang lässt der roboter ist mit sich
geschehen aber dann muss der roboter
auch wirklich ziehen damit er aufstehen
kann
aber wenn er dann fast steht wenn er
dann noch zieht dann die stabilisiert
dass sich er dann muss er wieder locker
lassen und das sind so lerngeschichten
die brauchen sehr lange bis die drin
sind
ein ziel million ist ja auch zu sehen
oder zu verstehen ist eigentlich
funktioniert das ich sage es mal entität
im ganzen tal eigene entscheidungen
fällen
also wird sich noch dazu kommen dass wir
uns selber entscheidet aufzustehen oder
könnte er jetzt auch selber entscheiden
sich wieder hinzusetzen das wäre
tatsächlich schon möglich entscheidet
jetzt schon wo er hinguckt auch da
werden jetzt viele denken mein gott da
ist ein algorithmus der sagt haben jetzt
nachricht soll jetzt nach links aber das
ist eben sehr wichtig wie diese systeme
eingestellt sind der roboter hat in der
komischen oper
in berlin im sommer diesen jahres auch
mitgewirkt und das war eine sehr
spannende situation weil da gab es ein
orchester da gab es publikum was
klatschen durfte und da gab es dann auch
natürlich sopranistin die zum teil sehr
nahe gesungen haben auch wenn ich etwas
entfernt etwas was wir im labor nie
haben also roboter sind eben tatsächlich
heutzutage so gut wie nie in der
natürlichen umgebung sondern immer spitz
in der speziellen situation die
einstellung dieser teilsysteme hören
sehen fühlen aufeinander ist eine sehr
spezielle geschichte die wir beim wenn
man auf die welt kommen einfach schmidt
mitkriegen
vielleicht wollen wir wieder hin setzen
lassen und nochmal schritte gehen lassen
uns also vielleicht noch wenn wir dahin
setzen dann lasst uns mal
sie haben jetzt mehrere mann gesagt ich
hätte halluzinationen weil ich sage der
druck so irgendwie freundlich oder ist
beleidigt wenn man nicht noch mal noch
mal es ist eben sehr spannend wir wissen
alle dass er das im prinzip kann und das
ist auch reproduzieren können aber im
einzelfall klappt das manchmal nicht
weil dies oder jenes zurück zu den
halluzinationen ja es ist doch total
normalen oder ich vielleicht ist das nur
bei mir so ich weiß es nicht
darf man irgendwie denkt dieses wesen da
wir denken und man hat so was wie
empathie mann hatte ich mir den eindruck
da guckt jetzt bitten oder so etwas das
sind alles nur natürlich interpretation
sie nennen das halluzinationen aber in
der science fiction welt ist es ja
trotzdem so dass wir dauernd mit figuren
konfrontiert werden die unglaublich viel
mehr können denken wir beispielsweise
auch an die fernsehserie humans in der
menschen mit robotern leben
und für romantische gefühle empfinden
stellt sich die frage darf man den
roboter wenn er kaputt ist auch
schreddern und so weiter also haben sie
denn selber diese fiel überhaupt nicht
doch natürlich also für mich sieht das
jetzt nicht so aus wie kindheit oder
lernen sondern mehr wie krankengymnastik
oder wie rehabilitation im krankenhaus
oder ein bisschen auch wie im
betrunkenen freund ins taxi bringen oder
das ist ja das sind meine assoziationen
damit also erstmal ist natürlich ganz
klar sie haben eben gesagt mir selber
mir und selber gibt es nicht da drin ist
kein selbst und kein kern und kann ich
und keine seele das ist ein
kompliziertes system das sich selbst
organisiert und dann ist es natürlich so
darin gibt es auch keine erlebnisse aber
sie haben erlebnisse ich habe erlebnisse
und die hängen davon ab was in unserem
gehirn im gehirn dieses biologische weil
wir hatten roboters ist und da sind zum
beispiel spiegelneuronen das heißt wir
haben unbewusste systeme in unserem
gehirn die erkennen bewegungen und
springen automatisch an und geben uns
das bewusste erlebnis design
zielgerichtet oder da stünde ein
biologischer agent dahinter und das sind
in dem fall falsche bilder der umwelt
also sieht es ähnlich absurde wenn ich
den eindruck habe keine ahnung der
teddybär lebt ja und gibt es denn ihrer
meinung nach überhaupt nicht ich weiß
nicht welche zukunftsvisionen dass ein
roboter irgendwann eben einig sein
könnte also bewusst seiner natürlich auf
jeden fall also das ist ja ein anderer
bereich in dem sich sehr viel tut
theorien des bewusstseins da habe ich
mich in dem letzten viertel jahrhundert
fiel mit beschäftigt natürlich bräuchte
so einen roboter dann nicht nur ein
bewusstes modell der situation und der
wirklichkeit sondern auch ein bild von
sich selbst in dieser situation und er
müsste sich mit dem inhalt dieses bildes
identifizieren ich nenne so was ein
selbst modell und dann würde es schon
interessant also eben kam auch mal
dieses thema körper ihnen wahrnehmung es
geht ja nicht nur um den kubus
wir menschen haben ja bauchgefühle wir
spüren herzschlag atmung usw
und ganz viel intelligenz hat glaube ich
damit zu tun dass wir außen etwas
wahrnehmen und es aber in uns ein
bauchgefühl eine innen wahrnehmung
erzeugt gleich und da fängt dann eben
die möglichkeit an im prinzip auch zu
leiden
es könnte dann roboter geben die nicht
nur ein bewusstes weltmodell und ein
selbst modelle haben sondern irgendetwas
so ähnliches wie wir wenn wir gefühle
haben also zum beispiel innen
wahrnehmung des körpers die sie nicht
als schön empfinden die niedrigen wert
haben für sie die sie vermeiden wollen
das ist ich sag das jetzt noch mal ganz
deutlich war ich bewusstseins forscher
bin ich persönlich glaube nicht dass es
das morgen gehen gibt werden geben wird
und ich glaube auch nicht dass das
übermorgen geben wird aber es ist sehr
wichtig weil manchmal die entwicklung
schneller verlaufen und viele sachen
zusammen wirken als wir menschen uns das
denken dass wir uns jetzt schon wirklich
auch über die ethischen und politischen
konsequenzen gedanken bevor wir zu
diesen kommen
es gibt ja in der schweiz dieses große
blue brain project dieser versuch das
menschliche gehirn nachzubauen von
professor an der universität lausanne
und der ep fn er angesiedelt würden sie
sagen es ist denkbar dass dieses sage
niemand simulierte menschliche gehirn
nebenmann bewusstsein
denkbar ist es auf jeden fall also wenn
wir ein modell es gibt in jedem moment
in unserem gehirn das was forscher ein
minimale hinreichendes neuronales
korrelat nennen also es gibt für den
kubus für die farben die wir sehen für
die bauchgefühle einen zustand im gehirn
es hinreichend um den hervorzubringen
und wenn herr marc raum und seine vielen
hundert kollegen diesen teil des gehirns
modellieren würden also wie die
information fließt in diesem teil des
gehirns dann braucht man die biologische
gehört wer darunter nicht mehr
also wenn man sozusagen ein computer
nationales modell hätte dessen was in
unserem gehirn passiert wenn wir
glückliche gefühle haben farben sehen
oder soziale halluzinationen
dann könnte man die im prinzip auch in
einem großrechner erzeugen mit einem
körper würden sie doch was sagen ja das
ist eben eine ganz spannende frage ob
wenn es nur darum ginge die
halluzination eines körper haben es zu
erzeugen ob man das nicht auch in einem
großrechner machen ja dann würde man den
körper simulieren aber sozusagen das
gehirn als organ braucht sozusagen eine
sensorische eingegangen das ist muss
natürlich auch motorische was
angeschlossen sein ob man das jetzt auch
simuliert sei dahingestellt aber zum
bewusstsein jetzt gehört natürlich auch
das konzept des ich kann auf die umwelt
zielgerichtet einwirken
ich habe mein selbstvertrauen ich weiß
das habe ich schon 20 mal gemacht und
wenn ich es wieder macht ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch dass es
passiert wenn nicht warum nicht dann
kriege ich plötzlich ein brausen und
rege mich auf oder passiert etwas das
kann man mit einem echten roboter körper
machen aber man braucht zumindest etwas
was mit dem organ gehirn interagiert
denn das ist sozusagen wie man sagen ein
relativ universelles organ was sich dann
auf das einstellt was angeschlossen ist
beim philosophischen problem könnte es
nicht sein dass wir sowieso alle nur
irgendwelche gehirne in tanks sind und
nur meinen wir hätten körper natürlich
also das bewusste erleben an sich ist
erstmal erscheinung also philosophen
sagen phänomenales bewusstsein im
erleben erscheint uns die welt wissen
ist erst noch mal was ganz anderes
also ein großrechner von henry markram
in 30 jahren oder ein gehirn im tank
könnte vielleicht erleben verkörpert zu
sein könnte vielleicht erlebnisse
generieren mit einer umwelt zu
interagieren
aber das tatsächlich zu wissen also eine
der sachen glaube ich die wir in den
letzten drei jahrzehnten gelernt haben
ist dass wahrnehmen
eine form des handelns ist das ist
wahrnehmungs immer etwas aktives wir
machen erfahrungen in einem ganz
wörtlichen sinn
wir bauen als aktive wesen die in einer
umwelt sich bewegen unseren
wissensschatz auf unseren
erfahrungsschatz
und da gibt es wohl sonst würden solche
roboter nicht gebaut keinen echten umweg
jetzt mal spricht er von künstliche
intelligenz müsste man auch von sowas
sprechen wie künstlichen bewusstsein
dann oder gibt es da noch einen
unterschied zwischen sozusagen unserem
computer im kopf und den computer in
einem sagen die jungen in 100 jahren
also das ist ganz wichtig dass sie das
fragen das sind zwei grundverschiedene
sachen die man auseinanderhalten muss
künstliche intelligenz die haben wir
heute schon ein künstliches bewusstsein
das ist eine zukunftsvision
und das hängt möglicherweise auch nicht
zusammen also man kann sich vorstellen
dass es sehr einfach gewesen gibt die
nicht eine sehr komplizierte geistige
struktur haben aber trotzdem starke
bewusste erlebnisse die leidensfähig
sind vielleicht wie bachelor studenten
an der universität mainz oder so das
heißt in ihrem seminar also da kann man
nicht vom einen auf das andere schließen
ob das erleben selbst eine form von
intelligenz ist das ist für mich noch
eine offene frage
es könnte viele einfache tiere auf
unserem planeten geben die sehr wohl
leidensfähig sind aber eigentlich nicht
besonders intelligent nach unseren
kriterien also psychologen machen ja
auch intelligenztests und da kommt dann
hinten die zahl raus wenn man ein
bisschen genauer hinguckt sieht man dass
es eigentlich ein profil und
normalerweise versteht man darunter
abstrakte denkvermögen mit zahlen
umgehen zu können räumliches
vorstellungsvermögen sprachliche
fähigkeiten und so weiter und fotos also
mehr so ein profil
tatsächlich würde ich aber behaupten
es gibt noch ganz unterschätzte formen
die ich auch als intelligenz wird
nämlich körperbeherrschung ja und ich
sage auch oft begreifen kommt von
greifen also warum spielen kinder herum
stecken sich dinge in den mund und
krabbeln herum weil sie dinge erfahren
wollen
ähnlich wie das glas was ich von als
beispiel brachte er hoffentlich ohne
schaden zu nehmen aber das sind genau
die
sachen deswegen finde ich auch nicht gut
wenn leute im prinzip kindern sehr
frühzeitig und welche mobiltelefone
geben man sieht dass man nur so rum
machen also lieber in den sandkasten
stecken und in die in die natur damit
aber das ist uns eben nicht mehr so
bewusst weil wir verkauft sind und weil
wir uns wenn wir jetzt unsere welt
bewegen
selbstverständlich bewegen
aber so fängt das an also die
krankenkassen sie denn jetzt nicht
einfach den mund nehmen und in frage mal
in den sandkasten setzen ist es nur das
problem dass der landrat diese gelenke
verstopfen hier nur was es ist ein rein
technisches problem also ja natürlich
ist es immer sehr sexy so ein komplexes
system mit neben einem zu sitzen haben
was was sie dann ab und zu an guckt ja
ich weiß natürlich die rote sozusagen
habe ich extra sie ihn ja schon gesagt
der marco habe ich verraten ja das ist
natürlich einfacher sensorische reize
die kennen wir auch da und dort mal
wir haben natürlich eine kaskade von
robotern auch kleine ich habe selber
auch mal ein entwickelt den ich im
rucksack mittragen kann wenn ich auf
urlaub gehe und ich habe was ich
ausholen will dann packt ihn aus und
kann man philosophen bücher mit ja und
sie schreiben also der punkt ist man
muss das tun und diese prinzipien die
auf diesen einfachen robotern gefunden
entwickelt und entdeckt wurden wo dann
leute ist anja gut auf zwei gelenken
aber geht es auch auf 50 motoren
sozusagen der des proof of concept
dieser roboter ist natürlich am ende
einer langen entwicklung die über jahre
geht also das labor ist seit über zehn
jahren existenz und es dann immer für
für mich beweisen kann man das nicht
aber man kann sagen solange es nicht
falsifiziert wird ist schon mal gut also
wenn diese mechanismen hier auf einem
lego motor funktionieren dann auf
robotern mit 34 gelenken wenn dann
plötzlich auch ein schweres humanoide
das system zum gehen oder stabilisieren
bahnen dann ist das für uns indiz dass
dieses kleine bauelement wo
wichtig sein kann und ein bisschen
universell ist dass man eskalieren kann
ich meine wir sind auch aus einzellern
wenn man der evolutionstheorie sozusagen
anhängt sind wir evolutionär entwickelt
und man kann sich auch die frage stellen
umgekehrt mal bevor wir komplex waren
wir primatenforschung gehen noch weiter
runter bis zu den einzeln auch am mögen
können interessante leistungen das ist
eine zelle die hat nicht mal sensorisch
und motorisch getrennte parzellen und so
wirklich einen eine membran die kann was
verspeisen und auch wieder ausscheiden
die kann auch antizipieren wenn man die
sozusagen alle hat 20 minuten ärgert
indem man die temperatur ein bisschen
anders
japan hebt oder senkt dann sieht man die
erwartet schon den nächsten 20 minuten
das jetzt wieder passiert also
intelligenz gibt es auch in ganz
einfachen organismen würde ich auch was
tatsächlich haben wir ja auch alle
prinzipien in uns drin die eben machen
dass wir lernen aber auch überhaupt das
leben denken lernen würden sie so weit
gehen zu sagen wir sind so etwas wie bio
roboter ja das klingt dann natürlich
irgendwie gewollt provokant wir sind
natürlich keine vielleicht auch gesunde
haare schneiden morgen also durch diese
form der selbsterkenntnis lernen wir
selbst wird eigentlich wie unglaublich
flexibel wir sind also erstmal ist es ja
so dass die künstlichen intelligenzen
die wir jetzt haben immer nur in einem
gegenstands bereich gut sind ja oder
backgammon weltmeister werden oder so
was
aber wir sind ja relativ generelle form
von intelligenz den offenen umwelt
interagieren können
eine zweite sache die wir gelernt haben
dass auch philosophen nicht so gedacht
haben dass es relativ leicht ist ein
computer zu bauen der jeden menschen
beim schach schlägt aber ein zu bauen
der die figuren selber fassen und setzen
kann
das ist viel viel schwieriger das heißt
was wir jetzt lernen ist das in unseren
körpern sozusagen über millionen jahre
geronnene intelligenz steckt ihnen auch
in der struktur unserer gelenke unserer
muskeln unserer sehnen
steckt sozusagen die wechselwirkung
geschichte der mit der umwelt unserer
vorfahren drin und die ist sehr tief
also körperliche intelligenz ist eine
sehr tiefe form von entega also
eigentlich euch so ein bisschen raus
wenn die bio roboter sind so bezeichnen
wollen dann sind wir ziemlich gut
gebaute oder wir sind ziemlich gelungen
gleichzeitig aber gibt es ja im moment
auch die große debatte darüber ob es mit
der vorrangstellung des menschen nicht
bald vorbei sein wird weil nämlich die
super intelligenz kommt da gehört er der
philosoph nicht posthum zu in den großen
waren aber auch stephen hawking schlägt
in die gleiche bresche jetzt und sagt
noch 100 jahre vielleicht dann wird eine
super intelligenz geben die wird in der
lage sein eben nicht nur sehr
intelligent zu sein sondern auch die
intelligenz zu verbergen das heißt wir
werden es nicht mal mitkriegen wie
intelligenz dienst und die könnte uns
auslöschen
hartnigk post schon einfach zu viele
science fiction filme geguckt
ich glaube das hat er auf jeden fall
aber er hat einfach auch ein punkt es
gibt da neue risiken
die künstliche intelligenz die robotik
entwickelt sich im moment so rasant dass
man zum ersten mal sich vorstellen
könnte könnte es denn so etwas wie ein
tschernobyl de oder in fukushima der ki
geben
also wir hatten das erst mit
atomreaktoren und so weiter wir haben es
dann mit den technologen als sie gegen
technologen sind ja vor einiger zeit an
die öffentlichkeit getreten und haben
gesagt wir sind übrigens soweit ihr
müsst euch jetzt als gesellschafter
überlegen was ihr wollt mit diesem
wissen wollen wir neue menschen sorten
klonen bauen
das geht jetzt bald und hier ist halt
das problem dass so eine super
intelligenz wenn sie denn eigene ziele
hätte welche haben könnten die mit
unseren gar nicht übereinstimmen und es
könnte dann sein dass sie natürlich sie
kennt uns ja sehr gut das was früher
ihre benutzer waren und die immer noch
denken sie wären eigentlich die user und
sind es nicht und dass es für sie ganz
vernünftig ist das von uns vor uns zu
verbergen dass sie das entdeckt hat und
erst mal lange abzuwarten uns überlegen
wie sie sich schützen kann gegen
eingriffe von uns dass wir das
vielleicht stoppen
abschalten das heißt rein theoretisch
könnte so etwas was bosse auch ein
single tonnen nennt ja wir haben das in
der wirklichen welt haben wir es mit der
finanzindustrie jetzt schon dass
plötzlich das geld sich so angesammelt
hat in den obersten 1 prozent das
eigentlich niemand mehr die kontrolle
hat auf dem planeten keine demokratische
regierung jetzt kann man sich vorstellen
dass wurde mit der künstlichen
intelligenz passieren
auf einmal wurden wir merken uns
verdammt da ist ein system habe sich
schon die kommt versprechen ist hofft
den immerhin im konjunktiv also sie
sagen das könnte sein sie haben auch
gesagt nicht basteln hat so viele
science fiction romane gelesen wie
wahrscheinlich ist es
ich glaube das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber es geht dabei um anderen punkt
genau über den ist ein verwandter punkt
ist das künstliche leiden wenn der
schaden sehr groß ist der passieren
würde in der zukunft und die risiko
wahrscheinlichkeit aber klein das wird
sehr wahrscheinlich nicht passieren
dann ist es trotzdem wichtig und
vernünftig jetzt schon darüber
nachzudenken und auch ressourcen dahin
zu tun
wie verhindern wir solche
zukunftsszenarien also einfach zu sagen
das ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich dass
löst das problem nicht
könnt ihr mir super intelligent ich
hoffe dass ich hoffe dass ich das noch
erleben werde ist eine andere frage aber
bisher gibt es wir haben jetzt gerade so
eine art generation 6 im labor
es ist eben system was ständig weiter
gepflegt wird diese hände des waren
früher zweipunkt greifer derzeit wird im
kopf die elektronik modernisiert also
das wird weiter gepflegt der rover
termin kann auch in einzelteilen
betrieben werden also wir haben es
vorhin von einfachen formen der
intelligenz und körperbeherrschung
tatsächlich ist ein einzelnes beines
robotischen fähig aufzustehen
ich finde zwei dinge wichtig das erste
ist im hinblick auf diese eventuelle
super intelligenz oder die singularität
auf die wir eventuell zu steuern
vernetzung hat erstmal nicht
grundsätzlich etwas damit zu tun ob ich
intelligenz als phänomen habe also man
kann geräte vernetzen
man kann informationen austauschen das
wird sehr schnell nicht kontrollierbar
beim mache ich mir keine sorgen egal ob
er intelligent wird oder nicht er ist
ein räumlich begrenztes system
er hat von der kraft auch wenn man sich
den finger auch ein klemmen kann wenn
man dem rhein fast also die einzel
motoren sind dann schon kräftig aber er
kann nicht wirklich schaden anrichten
also wir sollten natürlich uns klar
werden darüber dass komplexe systeme ob
er die intelligente nennen oder nicht
aber komplexe systeme die mit viel kraft
ausgestattet ist sind also militärische
waffen ein hohes gefahrenpotenzial sind
dann auch keine 100 jahre warten dass
das war schon vor vielen jahrzehnten der
fall und das vernetzte systeme aus
welchen gründen auch immer
ob apple gerne uns tolle services bietet
oder ob wir überwacht werden sollen es
gibt immer zwei seiten der medaille die
bürger grundsätzlich nie gefahren sich
also die erste bemerkung ist diese
beiden phänomene die erst mal
grundsätzlich nichts mit intelligenz
oder künstlich hätte gerne tun haben
sind da und die sind aus meiner sicht
überhaupt gefahrenpotenzial die zweite
bemerken ist aber da kann kann man jetzt
andere meinungen sagen anderer meinung
sein aber ich würde sagen intelligenz
kommt nicht hoppla über nacht also ich
rede jetzt nicht als gesellschaftliches
phänomen als forschungslabor sonnig rät
ihnen so was wie ein roboter oder in
sowas in einem forschungs rahmen
biologische systeme entwickeln sich über
die zeit
kinder können erst ab einem bestimmten
alter lügen oder aus eigennutz vorgeben
nein das weiß ich nicht oder das war ich
nicht oder sie hat gesagt ich solle es
tun
das kommt erst ab einem bestimmten alter
ob das nachgeahmt das verhalten der
eltern ist das ist mal eine andere
diskussion aber worauf hinweisen will
ist man hat eine verantwortung und die
hat jeder vorstellt ich habe mein team
und nicht haben die was mich angeht und
andere haben in ihrer domäne und das ist
vielleicht manch nicht bewusst aber dass
der punkt eltern haften für ihre kinder
und forscher haften für ihre roboter
wenn man so will und man muss eben
beobachten werden an forschung anstellt
wo ist man passiert etwas was ich nicht
abschätzen
man muss dann auch hier stellen sich
noch keine ethischen fragen ins
gedächtnis reingucken
und wenn man das mit hautenger füllung
begleitet dann glaube ich ist die gefahr
minimal also ich sehe wie gesagt die
bomben woanders versteckt
für positives menschenbild auch ich mein
vater hat bereits 1942 die gesetze
formuliert auch die ja auch roboter
ethische gesetze sind die fragen
tangieren wie sollte man mit robotern
umgehen aber auch wie sollten roboter
sich verhalten respektive wie sollten
wir uns verhalten damit sich roboter
entsprechend verhalten
und man kann ja im endeffekt sehen die
werden wahrscheinlich so gut sein wie
wir menschen aber eben nicht alles gut
was ich sagen will es ist eine
erziehungssache es ist eine
erziehungssache und wenn es so lange es
eine lokal räumlich umgrenzte maschine
bleibt also man früher im kopf war ein
modul was funk konnte wlan
das haben wir ausgemacht nicht aus
sicherheitstechnischen aspekten sondern
weil wir wollten das alles erlebbar ist
was im roboter vorgeht und sonst für uns
ein forschungs werkzeug und solange wir
nicht erleben können was in der maschine
passiert entziehen wir uns einen
erkenntnisgewinn das wollen wir
natürlich nicht
das heißt alles was der roboter tut und
bewegt und macht und auch was er denn es
spricht signalisiert ist was in ihm
vorgeht wissen läuft unser modell oder
was passiert hier
das trifft nicht auf alle roboter zu und
das hat natürlich eine gewisse gefahr
also die authentizität und die
protokollierung kyte ist hier ganz
wichtig und dann wie zum beispiel
arbeiten an einem konzept wo wir
studierende und den roboter gemeinsam
weiter bild natürlich auch völlig
unterschiedlichen stand ja und auch der
roboter fühlt sich nicht so gequält wie
die studierenden ähnliche phänomene
sieht man da auch aber naja also gut da
haben wir noch kein bewusstsein haben
das ist nicht so tragisch aber was ich
sagen will ist lernen um den kreis
wieder zu schließen findet in einem
milieu stadt wo man gefordert ist aber
noch nicht überfordert sonst wendet man
sich dem ab und wenn man forschung in
der art und weise betreibt
eingebettet in eine ausbildung und
eingebettet in einen sozialen kontext
der auch eine verantwortung mit
beinhaltet sehe ich das als relativ
unkritisch und ich bleibe dabei dass die
vernetzung an sich sozusagen die gefahr
birgt und wenn die wirklich insgeheim
intelligent würden und sie sind nicht
vernetzt
dann ist es auch wieder klein gehalten
ja aber in dem moment wo natürlich die
information und kontrollierte wege gehen
können
könnte das passieren wenn ich so auf
unser gespräch zurückblicke habe ich ein
bisschen den eindruck dass sie
eigentlich doch ständig optimieren
zwischen der biblischen idee der mensch
ist die krone der schöpfung und so
intelligent wie wir wird dann eben doch
kein roboter sein und dem bild des
menschen als mängelwesen aller arnold
gehlen der eindruck baut kommt etwas das
ist weitaus besser als wir und zeigt
diese ganze auseinandersetzung mit
künstlicher intelligenz nicht einfach
dass wir menschen eigentlich nicht mehr
so recht wissen wer wir eigentlich sind
wir wir sein wollen naja aber das ist
eben auch ein risiko über das wir noch
gar nicht gesprochen haben immer mehr
menschen werden nach und nach verstehen
dass wenn das im ansatz richtig ist und
das werden wir unsere eigene intelligenz
so nach außen tun dass wir nie eine
seele oder ein selbst gehabt haben dass
mit den bio robotern ist vielleicht so
ein bisschen na ja das hört sich
polemisch und provokant an
viele leute denken immer noch na ja aber
die maschine bekommt ihre ziele von uns
von oben rein gesetzt
aber das ist eine oberflächliche
betrachtungsweise wir beginnen jetzt zu
verstehen dass die ziele die wir haben
gesund zu sein viel zu essen haben
kinder haben in der sozialen hierarchie
aufsteigen dass das vielleicht auch
nicht unsere eigenen ziele sind sondern
dass die uns über einen millionen jahren
dauernden prozess von unten eingegeben
worden sind also als ein prozess der
selbsterkenntnis ist das natürlich sehr
verunsichert und es gibt auch nicht nur
so wichtig wie das war was sie gesagt
haben die verantwortung der forscher
es gibt auch die verantwortung der
gesellschaft die kann sich da nicht
davonstehlen
da sind wir wahrscheinlich bei einem
wichtigen punkt lassen sie mich den noch
aus kreisen
es ist ja so dass roboter und sehr viel
arbeit abnehmen aber sie werden uns die
arbeit auch wegnehmen
die sendung eco hat eine studie in
auftrag gegeben
der gemäss in 20 jahren ungefähr 50
prozent der jobs in der schweiz
verschwinden werden von robotern
ausgeführt werden und darüber hat eco am
letzten montag eine ganze sendung
gemacht
halten sie dieses szenario für
realistisch ja auf jeden fall natürlich
nur in bestimmten bereichen und nicht
einfach so überall also ich glaube der
philosophisch wichtigste punkt in dem
zusammenhang ist wenn es nicht nur
risiken gibt sondern auch nutzen
das heißt ein zuwachs an produktivität
dann muss dieser nutzen auch wieder
gerecht unter uns menschen verteilt
werden also wenn es durch diese systeme
und durch künstliche intelligenz große
produktivitätsgewinne gibt dann müssen
wir auch auf eine neue art und weise
darüber nachdenken wie werden denn alle
menschen an diesem gewinn beteiligt und
in dem zusammenhang gewinnt zum beispiel
ich nenne nur das beispiel dieses die
diskussion um ein grundeinkommen um eine
ganz neue bedeutung
also vielleicht müssen wir manche sachen
noch einmal neu diskutieren in diesem
grund höchst diskutieren ist ein gutes
stichwort sie sind an der reihe für die
sie gerne herzlich einladen ihre fragen
zu stellen die unsere experten
vielleicht auch mal gerne aufnehmen
ich hätte eine frage an professor
metzinger sie hatten zuvor die risiken
angesprochen fallen wegen der
künstlichen intelligenz mache auch die
chancen
mich würde interessieren liegt in der
vernetzung der roboter auch die chance
dass roboter die moralisch besseren
entscheidungen treffen können im
vergleich zu den menschen die ethischen
fragen sind ja sozusagen in zwei
schubladen also die eine ist wie gehen
wir menschen auf eine moralisch richtige
weise mit diesen neuen
handlungsmöglichkeiten um
die andere ist aber wie bringen wir den
systemen selbst moralisches denken und
moralisches handeln bei ich bring' doch
mal ein konkretes beispiel wenn google
selbst fahrende autos oder aber auch
militärische systeme in offenen umgebung
schnelle interagieren
dann werden wir sehr bald nicht mehr das
machen können weil das so schnell geht
das system den mensch noch einmal fragt
was soll ich denn machen
also stellen sie sich vor ein kreisel
drei selbstfahrende autos ein reh läuft
rein und zwei autos mit normalen
menschen sitzen drin
die google autos sehen es gibt jetzt
eine kollision
die müssen sich ganz schnell darüber
verständigen welche menschen sterben
ob das reh stirbt welche insassen
sterben es wäre nicht vernünftig dass
sie die menschen noch mal fragen
das heißt wir müssen denen so etwas wie
werte und die art und weise wie sie
lebenswerte berechnen irgendwann ein
geben weil die werden selbst moralische
entscheidungen treffen müssen und ein
punkt den wir noch gar nicht
angesprochen haben
viel brisanter sind natürlich
militärische anwendungen die dann auch
immer autonomer werden das macht
irgendwann keinen sinn wer bei
militärischen systemen dass der general
nachgefragt wird dann hat man den krieg
verloren
er hat das heißt wir geben auch
verantwortung ab an die maschinen und
das ist das problem das problematisch
aber im prinzip ich will ihre fragen
nicht ausreichen könnten künstliche
systeme viel rationalere und viel
ethische agenten sein als wir selbst
woher kommt eigentlich diese drang dass
ein roboter wie ein mensch aussehen muss
ist dass ich nie weil wir unbewusst
immer unsere eigene ebenbild schaffen
wollen oder das physikalische gründe
sehen wir das perfekte das perfekte
instrument tatsächlich ist man nicht
wirklich menschenähnliche hat sozusagen
zwei arme und zwei beine und kopf der
sich bewegt aber die äußere
erscheinungsform ist er von dem durch
es hätte vielleicht lohe den salamander
fusion doch aus den kinder haften also
ist hier diese starken konturen sind
eher reptilien artig und er hat auch ein
auge und so weiter und so fort er wirkt
tatsächlich menschlich er durch seine
art und wir hatten den auf konferenzen
oder auf messen wo kinder die kleiner
sind als er und jünger auf ihn zugerannt
sind und sozusagen keine
berührungsängste haben die erste antwort
auf ihre frage ist natürlich um
allgemeine geistige prinzipien zu
verstehen ist es überhaupt nicht
notwendig humanoide roboter zu bauen
die zweite ist dass die leute die das
machen sehr intelligent sind
intelligenter als jede künstliche
intelligenzen dass die auch lernen und
dass sie gemerkt haben dass sie
wesentlich mehr fördergelder bekommen
und öffentliche aufmerksamkeit wenn sie
humanoide roboter bauen
das ist eben auch ein gesellschaftlicher
prozess professor sie haben die risiko
ethische argumentation erwähnt dass also
potenzielle schäden seien zunehmend sein
auch wenn die wahrscheinlichkeiten
vielleicht tief sein gibt es in dieser
hinsicht bereits bestrebungen das was
kann man als politisch zum beispiel hier
und heute bereits tun wird auf
institutioneller ebene etwas getan oder
was würden sie empfehlen
na ja das wichtigste und das wird jetzt
sehr bald auch geschehen ist das eine
öffentliche debatte darüber in gang
kommt was wir eigentlich mit der ki
technologie wollen und zwar nicht als
forscher und philosophen zum beispiel
sondern als ganze gesellschaft da gibt's
ja unterschiedliche stakeholder und
unterschiedliche interessen
das militär hat andere interessen als
herr hielt zum beispiel ich finde ein
allgemeines prinzip an das auf das wir
uns alle einigen können ist dass wir
einfach leid minimieren auch in der
zukunft
welcher anteil der forschung ist in
diesem bereich in öffentlicher hand und
welche anteil ist privat und vielleicht
nicht veröffentlicht sondern oder für
das militärische geheim gehalten was was
ist so das spektrum
also das ist eigentlich sehr einfach zu
beantworten das ist gesellschaftlich
geprägt und hier gibt es große
unterschiede wie japan oder prinzipien
asiaten haben gegenüber künstlichen
system ein ganz anderes eine ganz andere
emotionale einstellung
die sind auch eher bereit etwas nicht
beliebt meine seele zu sprechen wo wir
sagen wie kann
wie kann diese philosophische
einstellung überhaupt entstehen
die haben auch weniger probleme sich
vorzustellen die sind ja sehr stark über
alt hat was ich robotik als lösung für
pflege und sagen assistenz als
persönlicher roboter zeuge im alltag als
rolle einzubauen
da sind wir europäer und auch die
amerikaner etwas verhaltener
was das militär angeht ist amerikaner
sicherlich vorreiter und google kauft in
großem stil robotik ein oder sagen wir
die forscher und zwar von universitäten
man die sind wie plötzlich rüben die von
einem hasen heruntergezogener klopp
sondern auch lokal noch ein
forschungslabor
da kann man nur vermuten wie hoch die
summen sind da dringt tatsächlich extrem
wenig nach außen und ich weiß von
kollegen dass sie zu verschwiegenheit
verpflichtet werden und da kann man nur
vermutungen anstellen was google damit
macht natürlich werde wird gefragt und
google sagt immer wir wollen natürlich
die menschheit verbessern aber da
passiert nahe robotik da wird also
sozusagen als bereichen extrem viel
geforscht und was man einfach sagen kann
mit sicherheit ist das alles entzieht
sich genau dem diskurs der eigentlich
notwendig ist was geht da was passiert
wenn ich da ganz kurz noch was erzählen
darauf was mir passiert ist ich habe vor
drei jahren in kyoto in japan auf einem
panel gesessen mit führenden robotiker
zb mit dem herrn die figur und die haben
gesagt ich habe ihn was über die ethik
der robotik erzählt und das ist eher
eine 1b
pro vorgegangen und hat gesagt ich finde
wir sollten einfach überhaupt keine
ethischen regeln beachten wir sollten
einfach machen was uns interessiert und
das eigentlich schockierende war das ein
großes sehr hochrangiges publikum
donnernden applaus gegeben hat das heißt
es gibt nicht nur beim militär
es gibt auch zwischen kulturen auf
diesem planeten ganz unterschiedliche
intuitionen zum beispiel würden
anscheinend viele der führenden forscher
in japan sagen
mit sowas wollen wir überhaupt nichts zu
tun haben mit ethik wir wollen einfach
machen was uns spaß macht und dabei soll
uns niemand stoppen
also es ist auch ein politisches problem
zwischen ländern und kulturen möchte ich
nach und ließen sollten wir den robotern
auch rechte zugestehen beziehungsweise
so den diese robotik oder in diesem
zukunftskurs auch so etwas wie ein
roboter recht die diskus eingeschlossen
seien
also der hat natürlich schon längst
begonnen dieser diskurs und eine
kernfrage ist was ist eigentlich eine
person also was müssen wir als eine
andere person anerkennen und eine sache
ist schon mal völlig klar
also die hardware wie viel kohlenstoff
und wasserstoff in der hardware ist das
ist ein ganz schlechtes kriterium dafür
ob man etwas als eine person anerkennt
das ist genau wie wenn man frauen in
saudi arabien den personen status
abspricht oder sklaven früher weil sie
eine schwarze hautfarbe haben also
hardware kriterien sind schlecht um zu
entscheiden wer es eine person wer
sollte rechte haben aber auch pflichten
haben und die interessante frage ist
natürlich wann müssen wir zwingend
solchen systemen rechte einräumen sie
als bürger behandeln
spätestens dann glaube ich wenn sie
solche rechte fordern und selbst die
theorie vertreten dass sie längst
personen sind also noch mal das
erscheint ihnen vielleicht ein bisschen
wie science fiction worüber wir heute
abend gesprochen haben
aber es lohnt sich auf vorrat zu denken
denken auf vorrat lohnt sich also wir
sind aber jetzt am ende unserer
sendezeit und ich bin bei meiner
verabschiedung angelangt und ich muss
sagen auch dieser stunde ist mir immer
noch nicht ganz klar ob ich mich jetzt
bei dir oder bei ihnen bedanken soll
bedanken kann ich weiß eigentlich nicht
mehr so recht wer du bist und werde mal
sein wirst noch weiß ich ob ein mann
oder eine frau bist aber schön dass du
da warst vielen dank vielen dank ihnen
dahin vielen dank herr metzinger für ihr
interesse
[Applaus]
[Musik]